finally after many many years we will  vote a measure a concrete measures to  fight the tax avoidance tax fraud we  have to avoid any kind of maneuver to  undermine his measure because we have to  obtain that the enterprise is the big  and the prices able to pay the tax where  they make profits and I will tell Julian  textgate is on sale the transparency  scale objective several software  multinational paid example I will have a  leases activity on the Holy See of the  near country-by-country reporting a  poppy poppy now a two dimensional  coordinate loves informational Shiv  Shakti public sector can permit for the  mobile hospital  what makes our heart right now a bit  heavy is that EPP and either they don't  really want this huge transparency what  they are doing they want to have some  sort of Emmental cheese loophole clause  in order not to report properly all the  time these data and right now what we  voted is a good report but it could be  better  [Music]